Dr. Cleveland selected six drawings, depicting
the logos of the SCP Foundation, the Global
Occult Coalition; the Chaos Insurgency; the
Serpent's Hand; Marshall, Carter, and Dark,
Ltd.; and Dr. Wondertainment, and prepared
them for testing with SCP-914.
All of the drawings were placed into Clockworks
on the setting "Fine," and this was the output
produced:
"A comic scene, depicting the Avengers, the
X-Men, and the Guardians of the Galaxy fighting
in New York City.
A flag, resembling the Nazi War flag with
the HYDRA symbol in place of the Swastika,
is seen from a distance.
Several politicians, including Mayor Bill
de Blasio, are seen evacuating Manhattan,
as the Dark Phoenix is about to destroy it.
Deadpool is also visible."